CHRIS VANDER MAY:
Hi there folks.
I am Chris Vander May.
I am a Senior Product Manager
here at Google, working
on the Enterprise Team.
And, we have, we're going
to have a little fireside
chat about Enterprise.
I'm going to switch over to
the Waves, so we're going
to have a Wave going here.
So, feel free to you add
things to the Wave, and
we'll try to get to them.
But, before we get started,
maybe I'll just have the rest
of the folks here on the
stage introduce themselves.
EVAN GILBERT: Hi,
I'm Evan Gilbert.
I'm an Engineer in our
Marketplace Efforts.
DAVID GLAZER: I'm David Glazer,
I play number 5 for the San
Jose Sharks, and do some
engineering for our
developer product.
SCOTT McMULLAN: I'm
Scott McMullan.
I work on the Enterprise
Partner Team and
Marketplace Team.
RYAN BOYD: And, Ryan Boyd.
I'm a Developer Advocate
Engineer working on
the Marketplace.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: So, thank
you all for coming out.
Let me ask maybe a couple
questions just to
get us started.
So, David, one of the things
that didn't get talked about
that today in the keynote
was some of the recent
announcements on storage.
Can you just give us, you know,
a brief summary of what was
announced today, and how
it impacts Enterprise.
00:01:27,74 --> 00:01:27,2
DAVID GLAZER: Yeah.
I mean the short answer is
it is not yet relevant to
Enterprise, but will be.
So, there was an announcement
today that we have a preview
of a Google storage for
developers offering out.
Which, lets people that want to
store bulk data in Google's
Cloud do so with a
very simple API.
Upload, download, get at your
00:01:47,146 --> 00:01:47,06
data.
And, when I say it's not yet
relevant to the Enterprise,
is as you saw with the
announcement of Google
App Engine for business.
There's a bunch of work, and
packaging, and integrations
that you need to do to take a
product that's good technology,
and have it be good
Enterprise ready technology.
That has not been done for
this preview product.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Scott,
contextual gadgets just
launched yesterday and Gmail.
Can you give us an idea of
what the Enterprise use cases
are for contextual gadgets?
SCOTT McMULLAN: Sure.
Contextual gadgets for Gmail,
one of my favorite, favorite,
favorite extension points,
we've been very excited to get
these out for a long time.
The reason I'm so excited about
them is, because, let's face
it, folks spend a lot
of time in e-mail.
And, they get a lot of the
inbound and they want to get
more efficient at that.
And, so contextual gadgets can
be used, and we already see
they're being used for
everything from, you know, I
have an invoice that
needs to be approve.
I need a simple
approve/deny button.
Let's make that easy, let's put
that information right in your
Gmail flow, and let's talk
to the system that actually
would approve the invoice.
To salespeople who are doing
biz dev, we want to figure out
where they got, you know, they
got a lead, do I know this
person, who knows it.
So, reach out in the
social networks.
Pretty much, any time you get
an e-mail, there's probably
some additional relevant
information from some sort
of Enterprise contact.
You can bring the bear to make
a decision better, and people
are starting to experiment
with that already.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Cool.
OK.
Let's go to the Wave for
maybe a couple of questions.
It be interested in a Google
Apps account as an individual
bringing all of my personal
Google services together
into a more closed and
manageable system.
Both, with a potential to
transition easily to a
professional service.
Thoughts on this?
So, anybody in
particular wanted to --
SCOTT McMULLAN: Can
you read that again?
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Yeah.
I would be interested in -- so
this individual is looking for
a Google Apps account to bring
all, I think, all of the sort
of personal services like
PICASSO and so forth, together
and transition that into
something like Google Apps.
DAVID GLAZER: So, the good
news is we've wanted that
ourselves for a long time.
And, I forget exactly when we
announced it, but a month or
so ago, we said, yes, we --
SCOTT McMULLAN: Last week.
DAVID GLAZER: Last week.
00:04:19,478 --> 00:04:19,338
OK.
It felt like a month or so.
SCOTT McMULLAN: A long week.
DAVID GLAZER: Yeah,
it's been a long week.
But yes, there's a little color
on it for anyone who's
interested, is internally there
has always been a distinction,
you know, deep in the system
between Google accounts, that
are part of a Google accounts
for your domain offering and
Google accounts that are just
used for regular
consumer usage.
And, the distinction was there
for an important reason, which
is, in the case of the business
the accounts need to have a
third party who have some
oversight over them.
There's an admin that has the
ability to create accounts, to
turn off accounts, to reset
passwords, to do things like.
And, to control what users can
do with the accounts in the
context of that work context.
That rippled further than ideal
into what services you could
use, and that's being
undone, and that's why we
announced last week.
So, hopefully that's what
the questioner wanted.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: I've
got another one here.
Which is a little bit, maybe
not super germane to developer,
but we'll take in any way.
When Enterprise is start moving
to the Cloud, with all the
period short or long, with
a mixed environment,
clouded on-premise.
What's the advice in
order to migrate.
He first e-mailed, then how
can I select e-mail address
from CRM on premise.
Maybe this is one that I will
tackle, since I work a bit
with the Enterprise
Deployment Teams.
So, generally speaking,
your order to migrate will
depend on your Enterprise.
So, it does make sense to move
individual users completely
at a single time.
And, if you do run in
co-existent mode, things like
these gadgets, contextual
gadgets, that Scott was talking
about, will certainly remain
relevant, and easy to use
for those new users.
And, beyond that, it's really
a question of how your
calendaring works.
RYAN BOYD: And, we do actually
have ways that you can connect
to the Cloud applications, to
your on-premise applications.
There's a that technology
called the secure data
connector, which allows you to
create a secure tunnel from
Cloud applications to
your on-premise apps.
And, make sure that you have
all the data in the right
context, whether it be in
something like gadgets
or an app engine.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Are there
any questions from the floor?
We're happy to take them too.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RYAN BOYD:
Tell him to repeat the
question, so that way in the
future if we can actually ask
people to go to the
microphones, that
will be great.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: So, the
question was is there any plan
to have a container, where you
can have a parent company and a
series of child companies
in Google Apps.
What are we saying about
that at this point.
It's something that we
recognize is very important,
and we're working on it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Yes.
Absolutely.
It's been available in post
[? ED ?], but multi-domain
management has not yet, and
is not today, available
in Google Apps.
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure
if I've just something.
So, apologies if this is buried
somewhere in docs, and I just
haven't looked in
the right place.
We're doing synchronization
things between our application
which stores a contact data,
and wanting to push those data
into the contacts within,
obviously, an apps arrangement.
The contacts as we see them
on our end, because we're
dealing with business
information is shared.
So, that contact, that person,
is somebody that every user,
you know, is able to
see and work with.
But, when it comes to pushing
them into the Google platform,
that's name spaces as far as
we've been able to see tied to
individual users that are
performing thesynchronization.
I know, in the case of Docs and
things like that, you can have
like global readable areas if
you're on the premium
00:08:14,198 --> 00:08:14,12
or paid versions.
Is it the same thing
with contacts, or if
I missed something, or is
that actually a gap in the
product at the moment?
Like a shared contact list.
RYAN BOYD: For the premier
version of Google Apps, there
is actually a Shared Contacts
API, which allows you to put
contacts in there that are
accessible to the
entire domain.
Were you aware of that?
AUDIENCE: No, I wasn't.
That's the bit I thought
I might have missed.
Thanks for clarifying it.
RYAN BOYD: It's definitely
there and you should
check it out.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAVID GLAZER: We
use it at Google.
It would be hard to get work
done at Google without having
the, you know, the whole 20
plus thousand people available
in auto-complete, for
example, and they are.
AUDIENCE: Excellent.
Thanks.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: OK.
Maybe I'll go back to
the panel for a second.
Let you cogitate.
Or, no.
Yes, I'm going to
go to the panel.
I got siked out.
Let's see, David how do you
think App Engine for Business
is going to change the way
that developers are building
Enterprise applications.
DAVID GLAZER: The short
answer is it will give
them more choice.
And, we think it's going to
give them a choice that they're
going to find really attractive
for many of their apps.
Did any of you have a chance to
attend the talk that Ben Fried
gave earlier today on how
Google was using Google
App Engine internally?
Just hands, just curious,
how many of you.
OK.
Good 20 or so people.
The, you know, what certainly,
what we found internally is
that there's a large class of
applications for which having
the power of App Engine to hide
the details from you is perfect
fit for many internal
applications.
And, it's a perfect fit,
because internal applications
don't always have a huge budget
in terms of engineering time.
They don't always have a long,
or a known long, life cycle.
So, it's hard to know how much
to invest in them up front.
And, therefore people are
limited in how much time
they can spend in actually
creating one of these apps.
And, if they have to spend a
week or two getting it
deployed, and managing the
overhead of actually getting it
out there, and they only have a
week or two to build it, that
means half their budget
is going to plumbing.
If you're building Gmail,
you have an awful lot
of development budget.
And, if you have to spend a
week or two or a month or
two on plumbing, it's OK.
You're amortizing it over
a, you know, multiple
years of engineering.
But, if you're building app
where you got weeks to invest
in it, the beauty of App Engine
is it takes minutes to do the
plumbing and the deployment.
So, for the apps where it fits
the programming model, which is
a growing number of apps, I
think it's going to be a big
attractive way to do it.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Well,
let's go to the floor.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: An announcement, a
couple days ago about Google
Apps Script having access
to on premises SQL.
I couldn't find any
documentation on it.
I'm assuming that's through
SDC and the FATE server
in the absence of --
DAVID GLAZER: JR are
you still in the room?
I saw you earlier.
Doesn't look like it.
But, the perfect person to
answer you question had stuck
his head in earlier, but no.
RYAN BOYD: I shouldn't
think quite yet, but
it was through SDC.
I mean, I think that's the
eventual goal of that sort of
access, is to go through SDC.
I think at this point
it's making direct
connections through SQL.
But, yeah, on the documentation
side it's definitely -- the
search for Google Apps Script.
At least the last time searched
for that, like a week or two
ago, it was actually that the
first result in the wonderful
Google search engine.
But, you should take a look,
and if you don't find the docs,
come see me after this, and
I'll definitely help
you try to find it.
DAVID GLAZER: There's a session
on app script, I'm looking now
if it was today or tomorrow.
And, that would be a great
place to learn more
aspect -- it's tomorrow.
So, there's a session tomorrow
on app script, where the right
people will be probably
answering your question
in the presentation.
And, if not, you'll know
what their faces look like.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Yes, next.
AUDIENCE: OK.
A prior session was
about the Buzz API.
And, is Buzz going to
be available with
Google Apps soon.
And, it's going to be
available, is there a way for
a company to be testers for
Buzz in Google Apps and
host their domains?
CHRIS VANDER MAY:
I'll take this one.
You know, we can't really talk
too much about the future
of that particular product.
And, so I can't say when
that would be available,
or even what the specific
implementation would be.
But, over time, we are working
very hard on giving admins the
ability to delegate authority
to various features.
And, to grant more granular
management capabilities
within a domain.
So, it certainly aligned with
the direction we're going,
but I can't comment on that.
DAVID GLAZER: There's
two things we can say,
because we've said them.
One is that absolutely Buzz
is going to be available to
domains with admin control.
That was part of the plan from
the day we launched Buzz.
And, so that's still very true.
And, the second is that we use
it internally in that way.
So, it's already in the stage
where Googlers are the
only domain this is
using it that way.
But it is in use, this
is not a wish this is
code.
AUDIENCE: And, is there a
way for a company to apply
--
DAVID GLAZER: We haven't done
any trust, or test, or program
or via program for domains.
AUDIENCE: OK.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: OK.
I have a question for Evan.
Evan, what sort of
security concerns should
developers think about.
Specifically for
Enterprise Apps.
EVAN GILBERT: Yeah, absolutely.
One of the things we're doing
with Google, with our
marketplace and the apps that
plug into Google, is they have
broad access to data that is
for the Google customers.
And, with that, there are a
couple things you need to do.
One is you need to think
about security very closely.
Your customers are trusting you
with their core data in their
Enterprise, and you need to
treat that data as if it were
your own, or possibly
even better.
And, the second thing with
that is don't ask for
more data than you need.
We're going to roll out more
features over time that will
let you get access, just
the data you need to
interact with Google.
So, if you don't need
access to a user's dock
list, don't take it.
Because, all it does is
creates a liability
for you in the future.
CHRIS VANDER MAY:
Great, thanks Evan.
Let me go to a question
from moderator.
Where does Google invest the
largest dev effort with an apps
in Enterprise, just so we
systems integrators can
adjust our strategy?
Well, David, what's your
take on this as an
Engineering Director?
DAVID GLAZER: There's two
halves to the question.
And, you know, one is where do
we invest our engineering
energy in Google Apps that are
relevant to the Enterprise.
And, the other is where do
we invest our Enterprise
specific energy.
So, let me say what
I mean by that.
And, I'll try to answer them.
I'm killing time here by
taking the question apart.
The most of the offerings
of Google Apps for the
Enterprise are the
offerings of Google Apps.
Most of Gmail for your
domain is Gmail.
Most of Google Calendar for
your domain is Google Calendar.
And, you know, so most of the
investment in Google Apps for
the Enterprise is actually
not Enterprise specific.
The bulk of the engineering is
relevant to all of our hundreds
of millions of users, including
the Enterprise specific users.
Then there is another set of
work which is the minority of
the total work, which is what
are we doing to take the
general offering and make it
relevant the Enterprise.
And, that probably is two big
categories -- there might be
another one I'm missing -- the
two big categories are
administration and inter-op,
are the two categories.
Administration means all the
things to recognize that there
is now a third party with
an interest in your data.
So, whereas if you use Google
Calendar in your personal
account, there's you
and there's Google.
And, that's the conversation.
Whereas, if you use Google
Calendar at your work account,
there's you, there's Google,
and there's your CIO, your
IT Admin, whoever that is.
So, all of the applications
that are Enterprise
relevant always have
some level of control.
A simple example, most of you
probably know this, a simple
example is are you allowed to
share a document with somebody
outside of your domain or not.
And, that's a choice that the
admin is given to restrict
the choices the users have.
So, that's one whole category
is admin controls over the
suite of apps -- turning apps
on and off, turning features
on and off, things like that.
The other category is inter-op.
And, you know, Chris maybe you
can say more about the kinds
of things we do there.
But, this is, you know,
this is very -- I think
of it as very bushy work.
It's not deep work, it's
lots, and lots, and lots of
small important features.
It's making the contacts
work well with the Outlook
contacts schema in detail.
It's a - I don't know do
you have other examples of
inter-op kinds of things?
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Sure, we do a
bunch of a inter-op related
work primarily to help domains
get there data out
of legacy systems.
Like domains that are trying to
move from Exchange, or move
from Lotus Notes, or want to
share a Google Calendar,
free/busy information.
Some of the users
with other users.
So, we do do things
in that space.
DAVID GLAZER: And, the last one
I'll add is the area that I at
least want to be the biggest
area of where we invest in our
Enterprise apps is the
code that you write.
And, that means, that's the
intent of the apps marketplace
is to put the hooks into our
apps, so that you all
can extend them.
And, I think the contextual
gadgets that were released
yesterday, that we just
talked about, is a
perfect example of that.
I would like to see the bigger
amount of velocity of new
features, new Enterprise
specific features being added,
to be coming from you all
out there in the ecosystem.
Building on top of the
platform that we add.
Because, Google tends to be
very well organized, and very
good at building things that
many, many, many people want.
And, we're not as well
structured to build things that
only thousands and tens of
thousands of people want.
But, things that tens of
thousands of people want are
very attractive businesses and
very important areas that
aren't our sweet spot.
CHRIS VANDER MAY:
Thanks, David.
Let me go to Scott
for one question.
Would you just talk a little
bit about the marketplace?
David touched on it.
What's progress in the Google
Apps marketplace been like.
SCOTT McMULLAN: We've
been very pleased.
We've been out for
about two months.
We've seen over a million
customers, or over a million
users, get access to
marketplace apps through
installation there.
And, I think one of the coolest
things most satisfying for my
perspective has been kind of
the breadth of applications
that have been adopted a lot.
So, we don't release a lot
of very specific numbers.
But, if you look at the types
of applications that our
customers are coming to the
marketplace looking around for
and actually installing it and
trying out, it really ranges
from, you know, single user
productivity tools like an
Aviary for photo
editing online.
Which, is something that
someone in the Marketing
Department may pull down all
the way, you know, to an ERP
Suite, to a lot of this
attraction, CRM and
projected management.
So, it's a breadth of kind of
interests has been satisfying.
So, it goes well for us to
continue to work with a
broader section of vendors.
And, really to try to --
to David's point -- make
Google Apps much more of a
platform that it is today.
We definitely got to start
that, but we really want to tap
into the creativity of you
know, both customers who want
to build things for themselves,
as well as other ISPs who want
to build things for sale.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Please.
Question from the floor.
00:20:30,838 --> 00:20:30,14
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I was curious how the Google
Chrome Store that was announced
today fits with the Apps
Store for Google Apps.
Is there any synergy
there that's planned?
Are they totally separate?
Is this like a consumer versus
Enterprise kind of separation?
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Yeah,
I'm happy to take
that as product guy.
You know, there's a very
clear separation in
these two marketplaces.
The things that you buy your
business or your organization
that works in a Google Apps
domain, you're going to get
those in the Google
Apps marketplace.
Things that are web apps that
are consumer focused, those are
in the Chrome Apps Store, and
they're designed to
work in Chrome.
There's not a Chrome focus
per se in the Google
Apps marketplace.
And, it is definitely
much more B2B.
SCOTT McMULLAN: I was just
going to say I mean there's
definitely, you know, an
organizational purchase
and a consumer purchase.
But, then there's that kind
of Prosumer, power user.
We got a lot of folks in
the marketplace today.
For example, SlideRocket, you
know, again as an example of a
high-end presentation tool.
You may just want to go out
and use it for yourself.
Finally, you love it.
And, then introduce it
to your organization.
So, having multiple kind of
channels in ways that the
customers can acquire things
from the web is really, give
us a lot of upside and choice
for users across the board.
Consumer to business,
everything in between.
DAVID GLAZER: Just two
small points to add.
One is, we talked about it
internally on the same page,
and how we described it.
And, one of the analogies, that
work for me anyway, was you go
to Home Depot, there's the
contractors desk where they buy
their lumber, and then there's
the desks where the rest
of us by our lumber.
And, similar products with some
commonalities, but different
businesses, different kind of
transactions, different
needs; therefore, different
interfaces to buy them.
My other point is that for the
places where the developer
needs are the same, such as
what standard are we goig to
use to figure out who the user
is, you know, what standard
are we going to use
for permissions.
Going to be based on the same
underlying security technology,
the open technology an
open idea, and so on.
So, places where it makes sense
to share it, it will be shared.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Any
questions from the floor?
AUDIENCE: Hello, can you talk
about your plans to enable
enterprises to manage their
internal deployment
of Android devices?
CHRIS VANDER MAY: I think you
should wait until tomorrow to
talk about Android
a little bit.
But, I would say that, you
know, there is device
management for iPhones in
Google Apps, so you can see
a clear trend right there.
AUDIENCE:
00:23:18,972 --> 00:23:18,92
Hi.
I know you cannot
tell too much about
dates and plans.
But, can you tell us a little
bit about what you're planning
with Google Voice, and maybe
additional communication
options like multi-video
conference and this kind of
--?
CHRIS VANDER MAY: No.
DAVID GLAZER: No.
RYAN BOYD:
Can say that there are
some telephony apps
in the marketplace.
And, there are other
solutions out there that are
looking to integrate with
Google Apps though.
EVAN GILBERT:
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Just a quick question
around Google Groups, and kind
of where that's headed, you
know, in terms of is it
something that they're going to
be APIs released, or is it
something that might merge
with other products?
Is there directional strategy
at least in an Enterprise of
taking Microsoft Exchange
public folders and
having a tool
to get that data into an
email enable container?
RYAN BOYD: We did actually
launch new groups for Google
Apps, and the Groups API,
that's just part of the
provisioning API
for Google Apps.
It does allow you to have some
management control over the
Google Groups and set up a
00:24:27,946 --> 00:24:27,46
new Google Groups, and
that sort of things.
You might want to
check that out.
AUDIENCE: With more rounds, so
right now the API let's you
manage the name of the group,
but not actually get to
any of the content.
RYAN BOYD: OK.
I'm actually not aware
of any APIs for getting
the content currently.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Generally
what we suggest to people that
want to do this type of thing
is that you can actually
use the site's API.
00:24:48,4 --> 00:24:48,06
You can create sites.
You can add data in the sites.
In [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
a very rich way to
manage content.
And, we've actually had
developers build sotware that
works in sites, OfficeSync is
one example of a piece of
software that saves
documents to sites.
So, that's one
place you can go.
Beyond that, the specific
things that we are planning
to docs, I, sorry to
Groups I'm not aware of.
RYAN BOYD: And, actually you
might also want to check out
there's a session tomorrow,
might not seem relevant by
the m but on gadgets
and Google Apps.
And, in that session the
speaker does go through a
ticket tracking app that
he built as a demo.
And, one thing that he does
sets up a group, but has the
email go to App Engine as a
place to then process
the emails and manage
some of the emails.
So, depending on your actual
application, there may be some
other solutions available.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Take a
question from the moderator.
how do we explain the keynote
emphasis of HTML5, and then the
use of Google Sites as is?
Any plans.
So, I'm not entirely sure I
understand the question, but
Philippe is in the room.
So, Philippe, OK, can you
maybe clarify for us?
RYAN BOYD: Can you get the mic.
AUDIENCE: And that's in that
product developed so much
over the last month or so,
so Iwas wondering
if there are any plans to --
DAVID GLAZER: Now, there's
someone who thinks on the
velocity the we like.
The product hasn't improved
in a month and he's
inpatient, so are we.
OK, now I understand
the question.
You know, obviously sites
uses its standard HTML.
It's a standard
web application.
It runs all of our browsers.
All of that.
What I think the center of your
questions you're saying, how
come it's not using the
coolest, newest features, how
come it's not taking advantage
of things that worked
possible two months ago, but
might be possible now.
I think, I don't have a
specific answer in terms of
Google Sites, but every
product team has their set
of priorities where they
look to enhance things.
And, looks for the ones
that add the most
value to their users.
We do not have a hot company
goal to say, hey we're going
to use this new technology
because it shiny.
An example that was shown in
the keynote -- was it in the
keynote this morning,
the Gmail one?
Yeah that was in the
keynote this morning.
When you're sending a mail with
an attachment, right, there's
a simple piece of HTML5 the
ability to drag and drop from
the desktop, that meets a very
pressing need in the product.
And, so, that was a those
a high priority one.
I think there probably are some
good enhancement possibilities
for Google Sites.
I don't know where they
are on that teams list.
So, I don't have anything
specific to say.
I just want to be clear that it
does support HTML, obviously.
And, priorities are driven by
what the team believes are user
of value, not necessarily by
using the newest technology.
EVAN GILBERT: I was going to
say quickly, I'm not sure if
the goal of Sites is
necessarily to be
the most advanced HTML Editor.
It's a lot about collaboration
and making it easier to built
websites, but not necessarily
to be the not cutting
edge of web technology.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hey guys,
thanks for doing this.
I love the idea of Google
Apps as a platform that's
extensible by the ecosystem.
Can you help us think through
how that's going to applying
on mobile devices, in
particular Android?
Should we be thinking about
that for merely as a web
experience, or via kind of
Google client for Google Apps?
How should we be thinking about
extending Google Apps in a way
that's going to be applicable
on a mobile device?
CHRIS VANDER MAY: I think
Sergey just said that the
native client and the web
browser were going to
converge at some point.
And, he's, you know, so
apparently he's just
defining the future.
So, I guess don't worry
about it until it
all gets cleaned up.
David, what were you
going to say there?
DAVID GLAZER: The first thing
that came to mind is something
that Vic pointed out in his
opening remarks this morning.
Which is open standards and
open communities and freedom
to choose is often messy.
And, it's a fun messy, because
it's the messy that's what
keeps us all getting out
of bed in the morning.
I think the particular area
you're asking is it's kind of
fun to watch the evolution of
these different tracks, and
crossover between them and
the hybrid apps that
are getting built.
And, yeah, you know, and where
the moving trade off point
between the benefits of
buildings a pure HTML5
application versus an
application that takes
advantage of device
specific capabilities.
All I''m doing is agreeing
strongly with the premise of
your question in saying that I
don't think there's a master
road map that anyone in
industry, let alone anyone in
Google could say for exactly
how those will trade off.
Certainly, personally, my rule
is when you can do the things
you want to do it HTML5, you
get much more reach, and much
more predictable long-term
reach by doing that.
But, not everything
can be done there.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Ryan, so you
spent a bunch of time working
with developers in the
Google Apps marketplace.
What are some major takeaways
that you've gotten from
developers, or major stumbling
blocks that you've encounter
that they should be aware of?
RYAN BOYD: Sure.
I mean so basically integrated
with the marketplaces is
quite simple overall.
It's basically integrating
single sign on with open ID.
A lot of open standards.
There are a lot of
libraries out there.
Some people are trying
to write their own.
And, that not only has
security problems assoicated
with it, but also has
usability problems.
So, you know, use some of the
tools that are out there to
make this really easy for you.
We've had marketplace
developers launch, or
create their applications
in like three days.
And, then we've had ones that
have taken a little bit longer.
But, there are a lot of
libraries out there to
help you with that.
You know, I'd also say like
test your applications, talk
to your customers about the
different use cases for your
application, and make
sure to support those
existing customers.
The existing customers are
often going to be the ones
that are going to install
your application first.
You're probably going to notify
them as soon as you launch
in the marketplace.
Because, they've been
asking for the Google Apps
integration for a while.
Take those existing
customers into account.
Create good experiences for
people when they install the
application to not only sign
up as a new user of the
application, but also link up
with the existing account.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Great.
Let's take a question
from the floor.
AUDIENCE: Hi guys,
thanks for your time.
Could you talk a little bit
about the strategic vision for
technologies like Wave or Apps
in a widget form, and how they
fit in with Enterprise
integration portal platforms --
like the Life Ray, the Weblogic
and the SharePoints
of the world?
CHRIS VANDER MAY: I'd love
to take a stab at this.
You know, there are probably as
many ways of getting a job done
as there are different
kinds of businesses.
And, what we're finding is that
technologiees like Waves and
Gmail allows businesses
to accomplish different
tasks more efficiently.
So, Wave is great when you have
a conversation that needs to
sort of evolve organically, and
go from a chat to email threads
to discussions, to documents.
And, we find that -- so Google
tends to use it when we do
offsite, when we do
an event like this.
And, that type of thing.
So, it becomes very, very
valuable in that context.
Whereas, you know, when you're
dealing with customers,
you know, you
get incoming email So, and
you have to respond to that.
And, one of our goals, Sergey
always said that he wants
email from Google to
make you seem smarter.
And, that's why these
contextual gadgets
are interesting.
Because, now developers,
yourselves, can write gadgets
that interact with email and
help you seem smarter, whether
it's CRM or whatever.
That sort of extensibility
built on top of Google.
So, there's two dimensions.
You know, sort of the, there's
the how your business
works, and there's the
extensibility dimension.
I think what's interesting
is that when you look at
Wave, you'll see robots,
you'll see gadgets.
You can add things to Wave.
We're continuing to add
extension points to Gmail.
You've seen left app extension
points, contextual gadget.
You can add gadgets in
other containers to
calendar, to sites.
So, for example, one of the
developers in the marketplace
is using Google Sites
as a repository for
virtual machines.
So, you can go and you can
select a virtual machine.
Is Skybook the name
of this company?
SCOTT McMULLAN: Skytap.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Thank you.
00:34:01,72 --> 00:34:01,66
Skytap.
I want to make sure
Skytap got a shout out.
So, using it as example.
But, you can go to your Google
Site, see all your virtual
machines, select it, and then
run that VM right
inside a site.
So, the notion here is that
we will continue to add more
and more places to extend.
And, there's lots of
real estate for us.
We have the document list that
hasn't been extended yet.
Lot of options within our
spreadsheets program,
we have App Script.
But, there will be more
that will come along.
So, we want to provide baseline
functionality that helps
you run your business more
efficiently, and keep your
data and safe cloud place.
And, then extend
ideally through third
00:34:46,78 --> 00:34:46,5
party development.
So, that's sort
of our approach.
RYAN BOYD: I'm going to kind
off add to my previous answer.
This another really good advice
for developers, that we
actually heard from a lot of
our vendors in the marketplace.
In partiuclar, you've probably
seen a quote, or you may have
seen a quote from Smartsheet,
where they're really finding
that their customers demand
this deeper integration.
Their customers find that
integration with contacts or
calendar, that sort of thing,
make their applications easier
to use and more efficient
for their businesses.
So, yes single sign on is like
the minimum bar for the
marketplace in terms
of integration.
But, you really want
to go a lot further.
And, and customers will have
those request for you.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Did that
answer your question?
AUDIENCE: It did, yeah.
Can I ask a quick follow on?
Do you
see yourselves gravitating, or
continuing to gravitate, more
towards the dashboard analogy,
or more of a construct,
deconstructed widget approach,
or to take sort of a
forked path and go both
directions at once?
DAVID GLAZER: You want to take
a crack at that, because you've
taught me most of how I think
about that particulars?
EVAN GILBERT: So, just to
clarify the question.
Dashboard versus widgets,
more general widgets.
Yes, so if I choose one or the
more general widgets, we want
to have what we dow with
Google everywhere.
And, the way it works isn't
always a dashboard, its work
isn't always a dashboard.
I think contextual gadgets
inside our gadgets in Gmail
are a great examples.
And, we also want to start
finding ways both to bring, you
know, your app into Google as
well as to bring Google
into your applications.
So, I think we'll see more of
that, because it's just too
hard to roll your own
set of UI widgets.
We don't it want everyone
who works at Google build
their own UI widgets.
SCOTT McMULLAN: I'm curious
about just in general, the
audience in the room, how many
folks are interested in kind of
building, you know, building
web apps from the ground up for
their businesses or for their
customers, for the sake of
having a web application versus
integrating a kind of an
application layer
on top of that?
so, application platform at the
Google Apps layer versus kind
of more classic web platform
and the service, infrastructure
as a service style.
Conversations about Google.
DAVID GLAZER: Let's try
to to break that into
a yes or no questions.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT McMULLAN: Can we have
an open conversation here.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID GLAZER: Three fingers for
"A," and two fingers
for "B" and -- how
many of you are, you know, one
of the things that you're
interested in that you're
thinking about doing over the
next quarter is building an
application, a web application,
pretty much from scratch using
platform technology
from Google?
Whether it be App Engine,
some of our APIs, but just
building a new application.
And, you're thinking of
building it on top of
Google technology.
How many of you are
in that category?
RYAN BOYD: May I ask how many
of you are looking at doing
that for internal usage within
your own company versus --
yeah, let's break it
to the yes or no.
Internal usage?
OK.
How many of you are trying to
launch that to the whole web
and get a lot of customers?
Great.
Thank you.
DAVID GLAZER: And, how many of
you are -- well first of all,
how many of you have an app in
the Google Apps marketplace?
CHRIS VANDER MAY: See this is
how we do market research.
SCOTT McMULLAN: Yeah.
DAVID GLAZER: Keep those
hands up for a second.
And, how many of you intend
to have an app in the
marketplace within 6 months?
OK.
Thank you.
CHRIS VANDER MAY:
How many of you would like
to go to dinner later?
[LAUGHTER]
RYAN BOYD: And, I definitely
encourage everyone to reach out
to the vendors that are in the
sandbox if you're thinking
about building an app
in the marketplace.
They have a lot of great
experience, and are happy to
talk with you about what
they've done, and the, you
know, the different challenges
and how they overcame them.
And, what the great benefit
is of the marketplace.
DAVID GLAZER: I'm going to make
one obvious observation, just
from that last pair
of questions.
But, I think all of you in
the room probably know this,
but I've gotten asked it
enough mostly by press.
The two first questions that we
started with about building on
Google's platform technologies,
and distributing an integrated
app through the marketplace are
intentionally and by principle
and design, separate questions.
The marketplace doesn't require
you to use our platform, the
platform doesn't require you
to use our marketplace.
We think those are good
areas that should not
be tied together.
They should work well together.
But, they should not be
required to be tied together.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Let
me try one for Scott.
You've been spending a bunch of
time talking with developers.
What sort of verticals are
going to be the most
interesting for developers?
SCOTT McMULLAN: Yeah
profitable ones.
Right now I'd say that
anything, things that
are customer facing.
Things that have been
historically asked of us.
So, I don't want to use
the word CRM, you know.
So, CRM, help desk.
Things that help you interact
with your customers collect
money and prospects.
And, that's a pretty broad
category, but those types of
things have been strong folds.
I would say, in addition to a
set of more admin focused
tools, we've got a handful of
vendors who are really working
with the IT shops, who are
adopting Google Apps, and are
extending our capabilities, you
know, around contacts
integration, migration,
management.
And, so things that help our
customers get more flexible
deployments have
also done well.
DAVID GLAZER: I'll tell you
that if I were, you know, just
thinking out loud, but if I
were trying to answer that
question for my small company,
and I were looking to do it, I
would look for an opportunity
to some one-off work for some
company whose already
bought Google Apps.
And, I'll go to them and
say, hey, I want to solve a
problem of yours internally.
I want to build a one-off.
I'll try to nail it.
And, then I'll see
if it generalizes.
And, that's just where
I would look for it.
So, you know, some of the apps
that Google's IT Department has
built for our own internal use,
some of those feel like they
probably are generalizable.
And, Google's not going
to generalize them.
But, somebody else, you
know, very well might.
And, I would look for those
kinds of things, where you know
you've nailed somebody's
problem, and then expand.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Well, Evan, I
know you spend a non-trivial
amount of time participating
with standards boards,
and thinking about
things like that.
What standards should we be
paying attention to from the
perspective of things are going
to evolve, we need to let
developers get more involved in
them, or are they going to be
more meaningful over
the next two years?
EVAN GILBERT: Yeah.
Really good question.
So, the core of working
with the marketplace,
is [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
integration.
You have to know who the user
is to get anything done.
And, closely related to
that is calling your APIs.
So, you need to go call back
into Google, to get access to
contacts, to get access to
emails to get access
to documents.
So, the two technologies,
they are OpenID and OWA.
And there's actually a
generation of OWA coming out
right now, OWA 2.0, which would
make your lives a lot easier.
You know, we have libraries to
hide a lot of the messy details
that oftentimes these libraries
themselves are not quite as
polished as they could be.
So, good stuff is coming
down the pipleline.
And, also for embedding
into Google, gadgets are
obviously key technology.
You'll note that all these
are open technologies.
Basically, we don't like doing
proprietary ways of integrative
with Google, because we think
that's not very hopeful
to the web at large.
And, it ends up being
self-defeating, because
people don't go to
proprietary platforms.
DAVID GLAZER: How many people
here have implemented OpenID
or OWA into an application?
How many people could explain
how OpenID or OWA work, whether
or not you've used it?
RYAN BOYD: A lot of less hands.
DAVID GLAZER: That ratio
is not surprising.
I -- when did I start
using the phrase?
Probably about 9 months ago.
I started going to the teams
and say, I want an objective
auth I can understand.
And, I said, OK, you don't
have to explain it everybody.
I want you to explain it to me.
And, they got to me eventually,
but it didn't mean anything,
because I had 9 months
to be indoctrinated.
But, m general comment on the
state of those particular
standards is they have
been too complex.
That is one of the reasons
that, you know, not every hand
went up, saying I've used it.
It's like if I said, how many
of you have used electricity.
Every hand goes up.
That wouldn't have been true
when electricity was as young
a technology as OWA is.
RYAN BOYD: I don't think
I'll be alive any longer.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID GLAZER: But, I will say
that OWA 2.0 is actually really
is threatening to succeed at
auth I can understand and
anyone else can understand in
the small amount of time.
It ain't there yet,
but, you know, it's
getting pretty close.
And, the basic premise of, hey,
there's locks, there's keys,
OWA 2.0 is a way for your
app to ask for a key.
And, you can use the
key to open any lock.
Sounds good.
There's a few details I glossed
over, but it's getting close.
And, it will be something
next year that you'll all
be able to raise your hand.
EVAN GILBERT: And,
actually a follow on.
If you understand cookies, then
you're a long way towards
understanding OWA 2.0.
RYAN BOYD: So, to plug my
session for tomorrow.
I'm doing a session with one
of our OAuth engineers,
Dave Primmer tommorow.
Whose apparently
in the audience.
Right there.
And, we're going to try to
explain OpenID and OWA to you.
And, we're going to be like
going through some of the
different use cases,
and how they apply.
We're not going deep into the
protocols, But, trying to say
there's all these different
flavors of OpenID and OWA,
when should you use them.
That's often been a question
that we've been asked by
the marketplace vendors.
And, then we're going to go
through like the evolution as
the process gets easier for
endusers, as each of these
technologies have been rolled
out in the different flavors.
And, we hope that it
continues to get easier.
I think there is internet
identity workshop earlier
this week, where these
standards are evolving.
I'm sure you can look
up Wiki notes on how
things are going there.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Any other
questions from the floor?
00:44:50,538 --> 00:44:50,198
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Alright.
Oh a prompted one.
SCOTT McMULLAN: You got to
keep asking that Chris.
00:44:53,9 --> 00:44:53,242
CHRIS VANDER MAY: I know.
Go for it.
AUDIENCE: OK, so,
totally non-technical,
non-strategic question.
With the growth of Google Apps
for Enterprise, are there plans
to add an administrator
track to Google I/O?
Or, perhaps, start an
administrator conference?
DAVID GLAZER: I see a person in
the audience who would probably
have something to do with
making that happen,
looking thoughtful.
It's a good idea, I
haven't heard it before.
I think in general, we're
finding that the breadth of
topics that are covered here is
getting very large, very broad.
And, so there have been
conversations about how to
shard it without losing the
ability for you all to sort of
cross-pollinate with the things
that aren't your day job.
So, we're trying to
balance those two.
But, specifically would be for
administrators of Google Apps
is the general area that
you think would be worth
some focused attention.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID GLAZER:
So, let's do the
market research.
Of the people in this room, not
quite a random sample, how many
of you would find Google I/O
next year more interesting
if there were an
administrator track?
OK.
SCOTT McMULLAN: Well
considering last year we didn't
actually have an Enterprise
track at all, I think a
year is a long time.
I think we should hope
to have that next year.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: That's
a great suggestion.
Thank you.
Anybody else has a suggestion
that you would like to throw
our way, and watch us wince?
No, go for it.
RYAN BOYD: You look
like you have one.
Can you go to the mic?
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Should
I walk down the isle and
do my Jerry Springer?
AUDIENCE: I'm noticing in the
universal navigation more menu
now the apps that you installed
are in a determined sort
order, alphabetical.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Isn't that
funny what happens when you
don't write a requirement?
AUDIENCE: It was reversed
alphabetical for a week or two.
RYAN BOYD: It was, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'd like to have
some control over the
naming of the apps.
So, if you installed Acme app.
EVAN GILBERT: Just put
a z in front of it and
you'll be all set.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: You're
talking as an administrator.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and this
is not to overcome the
sorting problem so much.
It's just the branding
of the tool
that we provide for business
use in the organization.
We'd like to have some control
over that in the menu list.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Thanks
for that suggestion.
It's a great one.
It's something that we will
definitely put on the list.
EVAN GILBERT: I say it's also a
good sign that we should have
enough apps now that people are
using, so that you need
to sorrt the word
through and through.
AUDIENCE: This is another kind
of administraty or PE question.
I know for our domain, we
were using Google Accounts
before Google Apps existed.
And, for some of us, like my
email address has a Google
account and a Google Apps
account at the same time.
And, depending on where I log
in, and the order in which
I log in, I would receive
vastly different things.
I have no idea who to ask
for help about this.
But, you guys are
stuck on stage, so --
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Yeah,
we're sorry about that.
So, this is what Dave was
referring to earlier.
There's this name space
conflict between
those two areas.
And, we're working very
hard to resolve that.
So, that this will all
sort of magically work.
And, you should look at it
magically working soon.
And, you won't have
to do anything.
DAVID GLAZER: Yeah.
I will say that we are making
Googlers suffer a lot of
pain, so we get it right.
Before, you have to
suffer more pain.
Google has the most of
those conflict accounts
of any domain out there.
We ran the stats.
We knew this was going
to be a heart problem
and ran the report.
And, Google.com was far and
away the biggest instance
of people with those
collision accounts.
And, we found a few ways
not to reconcile them.
Let's put it that way.
CHRIS VANDER MAY:
So, we're sorry.
We're working on it.
Yes?
00:49:25,738 --> 00:49:25,098
AUDIENCE:
Hi.
Since we're asking
administrator questions, here's
a hypothetical for you.
Let's say that you're an
administrator in Enterprise,
and you're trying to
evangelize, and you're trying
to encourage people to move
away from your legacy systems
and onto a more of a
cloud based approach.
And, from your Enterprise
-- OK, woops there
goes the hypothetical.
But, I have, people have been
telling me, the two biggest
concerns I'm getting from
people are one, they don't
trust the concept of
cloud completely (i.e.
I don't trust storing in
someplace that's not, that
I can't physically touch).
And, then the second concern
is a privacy concern..
You know, where, I don't trust
a third company to have access
to my data, even though
they said they're not
going to touch it.
And, I'm sure you've come
across these questions before.
How would you, what will be the
best way to explain and ease
those concerns to someone, who
to say is non-technical,
but signs checks.
DAVID GLAZER: So, the advice I
would give your friend, who
hypothetically -- [LAUGHTER].
The first thing I'd say is
those are very legitimate
concerns, those are the right
questions that we all should
you, know, be asking even
when we forget to ask them.
Because, you know, the
exosure is very real.
The hypothetical risk is there.
So, you know, although it's
tempting for us here to make
fun of those concerns -- I find
it tempting sometimes when I'm
impatient -- that's
the wrong answer.
Right?
Those are legitimate concerns.
I usually do by analogy
is how I start.
And, my preferred analogy to
start with is -- so what you're
telling me is you don't
have a bank account.
And, you keep your money under
your mattress, because you
don't trust someone else to
manage information that's
important to you, and that you
would worry about it being
exposed to the rest
of the world.
And, 60 years ago, 70 years
ago, that would have been a
legitimate topic
of conversation.
00:51:23,898 --> 00:51:23,158
Right?
It's like is it safer to
keep my money under my
mattress, or in a bank.
You know, maybe 100 years
ago, right, to get --
EVAN GILBERT: Years
from now mail.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID GLAZER: But, that's a
place where over time the
standards, the habits, and
the level of trust and the
practices that made that
trust worthy have grown.
And, now it is obviously more
secure and more say to keep my
money in a bank, than it is
with a third party, with many
third parties, than it is to
keep it under my mattress.
And, I think that trend is
happening in many, many
areas of our lives.
Right.
You know, the slightly tired
one now, but about the same
time frame one from Nicholas
Carr's book, The Big Switch is.
So, you obviously have your
own generator, because you
don't trust the third party
to provide your power.
Right.
That doesn't quite hit the
privacy concerns, but it does
hit some of the same ones.
And, I think that reasoning by
analogy to say, hey, it's a
very legitimate question.
But it's a question of when in
this case, with this third
party, for this data,
it's a good deal.
And, the answer more and
more is it is a good deal.
And, then my last answer which,
depending who I'm talking
to, is very useful.
I've had this conversation with
my wife, and my daughter's
school is a customer
of Google Apps.
And, so you know, I've
had it with people
who aren't technical.
My last answer is we at Google
do not do anything that's not
available to you all, as Google
Apps users, to secure
our Google Apps data.
We keep all of our
announcements, all of our
product plans, all of our
competitive information,
you know, all of that.
All of that's exchanged by
Gmail, you know, all of that
is in Google Docs, all
of the presentations.
And, they're secured with
the same mechanisms that
we offer to all of you.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: I think
there's one other dimension
there too that I'll add to
this, which is that, you know,
as developers you have the same
problems that Google does in
terms of selling Google Apps.
We have to address
these same issues.
So as you go to cloud
services, you have to
address these same issues.
So, I think David's answers are
good, but you may need to start
looking at ways in which
you can validate the
strength of your bank.
We went through, we did
SAS 70 Type I and Type
II certification.
Type II is where you get
somebody from a third party to
come and say did you do Type
I, and then they say, yes.
So, it's valuable.
But, obviously, we did have a
third party come in and look
at the way in which we
maintained passwords.
And, which, you know, just show
that data is obfuscated at
rest and things like that.
So, really paying attention to
best practices, and insecurity,
and all those things are
certainly paramount.
EVAN GILBERT: And, actually
some obvious ones from the
security question before, even.
Keep your secret, very secret.
Make sure no one gets
access to them.
Log access to data, so you
know who's talking to what.
And, try to only give
data out when people are
online at their computer.
That's something we're doing at
Google a lot more now, is
saying if you don't have an
active login session from a
user who's been there with
OpenID in the last x minutes,
then you shouldn't have access
to data unless you have this
super duper master key,which
is hidden away and
locked in a safe.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: No
more sticky notes.
OK. next.
AUDIENCE: So as a follow on to
that, there's some environments
where -- I work in the defense
and intelligence space, and
that can't go to the
public cloud right?
I have to do in internalizing.
Are you guys thinking about
offering these platforms in a,
you know, in a way we can bring
it in inside the firewall?
CHRIS VANDER MAY: We are
intentionally not deploying
Google Apps onto small hardware
devices and things like that.
Because, that is not the cloud.
We don't get the same economies
of scale that we do when we get
to replicate data across three
different data centers,
you know, in real time.
However, you know, when you
look at the Feds, now defense
is probably a different deal,
you know, or you lok at
healthcare, some information
like HIPAA data, is very,
very special data.
And, it needs to be
treated differently.
And, you know, you just
shouldn't ever send that
information in email periods.
It does not matter who
your cloud provider is.
You just should not be
sending HIPAA data out.
So, you know, similarly there
are additional requirements by
the federal government, to do
things like make sure there
are very specific kinds
of background checks.
All of us went through
background checks beore we got
hired at Google, as did all the
people that run our servers.
But, there are some very
specific types of background
checks that you have to go
through if you hold
defense data, as you
probably are aware.
So, you know, those types of
issues, I think are going to
get -- my hope is that actually
they get ironed out a
little bit more overtime.
And, we see, you know, the
government able to move more,
and more to the cloud.
You know, I think it's a
great opportunity actually.
EVAN GILBERT: Yeah, it's also
worth noting that one of our
goals is not to force you to
move all of you data into the
cloud in order to get
value out of Google.
So, you know, you use your
email with Google but continue
to keep your privacy sensitive
data, even behind your
firewall, and connect with SCC
to it, and variations of that.
You can keep your data stored
in a separate system with
its own privacy guarantees.
And, use Google for login
if you want to, or not
use Google for login.
So, there are many ways you can
combine something that has
different security guidelines
with what you do with Google.
AUDIENCE: You know, I
guess, if you don't mind.
So, a scenario I have in my --
you're right, I think, you
know, federal civilian agencies
are going towards
the public cloud.
Staff getting more
comfortable with that.
Defense, hopefully,
might follow on, start
considering more.
But, in some spaces, we have
environments that don't have
internet connectivity, let's
say, but we've got multiple
data set, we've got private
clouds going on, but they want
this kind of functionality.
So, I'm guessing
the answer's no.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: It's
really not on our road map.
I mean, there are things that
we're really, really good at,
building data centers
is one of them.
And, you know, we do deploy
Google search appliance, which
can run behind your firewall.
But, that's a very different
subset of technology.
AUDIENCE: Alright.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE:
Also, on the same topic.
I'm actually out of D.C., and
my former life, at those
background checks, and
many government clients.
But, in my new life, I watched
yesterday with our gadget,
WayFind and then Two Clicks,
we had two-legged O-auth to
all of the people's email.
And, not to say they were not
doing all the right things for
that, but it's a scary thought.
That, in Two Clicks, you
know, everything is there.
You guys are doing all the
right stuff, but our little
startup is doing all
the right things.
And, I would consider -- and I
brought up in the panel of four
with Ryan and Steve about,
you know, certain people
having access to it as
opposed to everybody.
Like for example, I actually
ask client that were work with
that I know are testing apps at
their companies, and they
might have 100,000 users.
But, you know, if they're
installing a gadget, wouldn't
it be nice if 1 person could
try it out or 5, as opposed to
everybody, or even
just a few people.
But, not from their practical,
like should I pay for 50 users
perspective, more from the like
is this legit, do I trust
this kind of perspective.
And, also in the apps set up
itself, in terms of in the
marketplace, things that relate
to security that go beyond
just, you know, their
privacy policy.
I was just curious if you're
planning on moving in
that direction at all.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Yes.
Very strongly.
We're planning a whole bunch
of things in that area.
We would really like to lead
the industry in this space.
You know, we recognize that as
more and more of data is stored
in the cloud, you need to be
able to allow people to get
access to it, manipulate it, or
allow those applications to
only touch objects that
they create, and so forth.
Or, as Evan was pointing,
only touch them when
you're in session.
So, these types of things
are very, very, very
important to us.
And, we've got a bunch
of stuff in the works.
And, we're almost out of time.
So, we've got 40 seconds.
We can let you go early.
EVAN GILBERT: Speed round.
CHRIS VANDER MAY: Or, we
can do a speed round.
I once saw Michael Moore do a
speed round, it was amazing.
Well thank you for coming
today, I really appreciate it.
Thank you to my panel Evan, and
David, and Scott, and Ryan.
And, enjoy the rest
of Google I/O.
Have fun.